يمكن ان تحدث خلايا الدم المصنعه التي
تثبت من خلايا الجذعيه للمتبرعين ثوره في
العلاجات لكثير من الاشخاص ومنهم الاشخاص
الذين يعانون من الترامات الدم مثل 300
ايضا المصابون مرض فقر الدم المنجلي اي
انتاج خلايا الدم حمراء غير طبيعيه الشكل
كذلك المرضى الذين يعتمدون طوال الوقت على
عمليات النقل المنتظمه او تبادل الخلايا
الحمراء هؤلاء المرضى اعدادهم في تزايد
ويحتاج بعض الاشخاص الى ما يصل الى اثنا
عشر وحده من الدم كل اربعه الى سته اسابيع
كما ان مزود الخدمات الطبيه يعانون
باستمرار من نقص في المتبرعين وبالتالي قد
يكون ايضا خيارا علاجيا لاولئك المرضى
الذي لديهم فصائل دم نادره لان الدم
المصنع سيسمح باختيار فصائل الدم التي
تزرع في المختبر